they're heading as we made it was
reflections of functions but this is not
the only kind of reflection we can do so
he goes on a three now I'm so confident
that we can do this quickly we're going
to do it together if instead of the
minus sign being inside attaching to the
X right if it were on the outside what
would happen well let's have it got this
right it's the same f of X we began with
so I'm gonna write minus and then here
comes the entire function right it's
gonna be x squared plus 5x plus 6 okay
now we've already factorized this right
what's the factorization of that thing
on the inside X plus 2 X plus 3 so what
does this factorization tell you what
did it tell us before why do we
factorize why do we ever find guys it's
so we can find that that the
x-intercepts right what are the
x-intercepts negative 2 negative 3 now
hold on
that's a good idea you needed one of
these as well you need a horizontal axis
so negative 2 negative 3 they were just
like the very first graph we did this
morning right so let's go ahead can you
put this on with me 1 2 3
roughly okay so you've got the
factorization okay but see when we next
looked at what to do we thought oh I've
got x-intercepts I should find the
y-intercept what's the Y and it's at
this time now you're like oh there's the
six bar there is a minus sign out the
front of the whole thing so it's
actually negative six isn't it so
instead of being up here that's all the
way down here okay now don't work it out
have a thing for me right what is your
axis of symmetry going to be how
different will it be to previously it's
going to be the same right it's still
between the intercepts the intercepts
are still negative 2 and negative 3 so
still between there but the y coordinate
of the vertex is going to change do you
see this when you put in that negative 2
and 1/2 into here yeah you're gonna get
negative 1/4 in here but there's a
negative out the front as well
right so you're going to get this guy up
the top that's positive 1/4
send it again yeah that's there's my
negative six right down there so let's
go ahead let's draw this graphically
okay you're ready to actually construct
this there we go use your machination
okay now we did this much faster than
the others because I think we're
starting to get oh I'm familiar with
these things how would you describe this
graph in relation to the very first one
that you drew again it's a reflection
but it's different kind yeah okay what
are you thinking okay now we can think
about symmetries here right now this
particular function actually does not
have any symmetry itself right if I
reflected it that way or this way I get
different function but is related to the
original word story what do you see
right yeah that's right that minus sign
it touches to the whole thing right okay
so here's a way we can think about this
right see this guy here this is that
hardly felt real press it I'll come to
in a minute see how this is a reflection
across the y-axis right so in other
words it's changed horizontally we
shouldn't have been surprised by that
because the minus sign is attached to an
X the X is the horizontal axis right so
you put a minus sign on X you flip
horizontally okay but this time here
that minus sign it's not actually
attached to the X maybe if you can write
this with me might be hand if you write
this in a different color because I want
to highlight it for you right see this
minus sign it's actually attached not to
the X but to the why
do you see that like I've multiplied
both sides by negative one
where's the minus sign it's here on the
Y the Y is a vertical thing right so
this is not a horizontal flip this is a
it's a vertical flip it used to be
concave up now it's concave down okay so
we cannot summarize this just like we
did before right let me get rid of this
why equals here we go y equals negative
f of X right it's also a reflection but
because it's a it's a vertical
reflection right which axis is it
reflecting across not on Y axis it's the
x axis across the x axis of whenever we
started with f of X okay now I'm not
even gonna write this on the board I'm
gonna ask you to do one last one we did
it's just this particular whiteboard we
did F of negative x we did negative f of
X the last one what you do is to pop
both Negin is on if you had a negative
inside there and also a negative outside
so this is what I'm asking you to draw
okay can I ask you to draw this last one
okay fit it onto a final set of axes and
then I'm gonna come around and cook call
me over when you've finished I'll see if
you've got the right track